would you give this to Charles Barkley
please and he
you ready
yeah yeah let's go
first name is
Joel embiid oh yes indeed Joel embiid
um
All-Star selection
leading scorer in the league 33 points a
night 10 rebounds four assists shooting
53 percent
number one is scoring number 11 in
boards has 27 games of at least 30
points that's 27 games in the 38 he has
played so wow Joel embiid
congratulations All-Star Reserve from
the East oh yes indeed I don't hope I
got somebody nobody know what's crazy we
ain't even seen these people act like
that like no no in years past we did but
not not anymore oh the mod DeRozan DeMar
DeRozan of the Chicago Bulls is a la
star for the sixth time uh averaging 26
5-5 shooting 51 percent
16 games of at least 30 points he's 15
in the league in scoring so DeMar
DeRozan shout out to my boy Mark
eversley are the Bulls
okay yes shout out I bet very important
to get that out there at this point I'll
just take the third since we're going in
order right here no problem no no we
didn't we go one two three don't go one
two four three
from the Boston Celtics Jalen Brown oh
yes of course yes that's a easy
absolutely absolutely an easy pick and
uh for a guy who's averaging a
career-high 27 also a career-high seven
rebounds 27 shooting 49 which is a
career high 14th in the league in
scoring
and the Boston Celtics of course with
the best record in the biz at 37 and 15.
27th and 14th Dr O'Neill thank you sir
sir he said 20. he said 27 27 27 14. you
know defense is optional I tell you
from the Miami Heat bam out of Bio yes
yes congratulations his second All-Star
selection and this is sixth season uh
21 10-3 shooting 54 he's had double
digits and 63 straight games
number two in the league and points in
the paint per game behind Giannis he's
12th in rebounds Miami is plus 129 when
he is on the floor minus 113 when he is
off the floor bam out of Bio maybe
there's a plan more just give this to
Charles if you vote thank you brother
just getting interesting here it is
wow
Drew holiday yes from the Milwaukee
Bucks yes
the second best record in the Eastern
Conference Drew holiday 19 points five
rebounds and seven assists he's played
in 40 of the Bucks 51 games
he didn't play it enough to get filmed
well he filmed one of them
he plays for the bucks
you know what's great sorry about that
Drew second All-Star selection 14th
season his first All-Star since 2013. he
should have been more in Philadelphia
one of the best players in this league
congratulations to Drew holiday here you
go jet yes indeedy take your time Kenny
so you can go through the my mind okay
listen we have we should have every
player please upstairs I know that's
Steve villarello up there turn the
volume up too
from the New York Knicks
Julius Julius Randle
star again his second selection
um
25 11 and 4. he's played in all 52 games
for the New York Knicks leads the east
in double doubles 20th and scoring
seventh in rebounds
third and double doubles that has the
most in the East and so
Julius Randle is an All-Star I'm going
to give you the last one well this is
the last one or the East wow no I'd like
you to do it sure yes without question
without question
who will be the seventh reserve for the
east from the Indiana Paces Tyrese
Halliburton very nice and well deserved
for Tyrese Halliburton who leads the NBA
in assists
since he's been out the Pacers have gone
one and nine he's got 24 games of at
least 10 assists leads the league as I
said 20 points four rebounds tennis is
shooting 48 from the field 40 from Deep
and Tyrese Halliburton rounds it out for
the
reserves from the Eastern Conference
Western Conference you want a million
reasons Western Conference reserved Dr
O'Neill start things off thank you sir
there you go going three two one again
from the Memphis Grizzlies John Moretz
well deserved without question y'all got
tape on them good
27 6-8 uh 17 games of at least 30.
16 games with double-digit assists he's
11th in scoring he's fifth in assists
fourth and triple doubles
with five
I'll take the second one okay then I'll
then I'll hand it out no problem we saw
it going from three to four now yeah
we're all over the place we always go
one two
from the Sacramento Kings yes domatis
sabonis okay that ain't the only one
we don't know I don't know we don't know
that this was the easiest there's no
denying the year he's had a 1912 and
seven leads the vegan rebounding
uh that's impressed number one in double
doubles number three in triple doubles
with six wow and um no he's just he's a
monster he's played in 48 of their 50
games so demon is sabonis and All-Star
for the third time in his secondary
Kings have been awesome they I'm hoping
they have two this year jet well we'll
see if this is one of them you're hoping
from the Oklahoma City Thunder say
gilges Alexander
and that is another one that uh yeah
that becomes as a surprise surprise no
one no one first time he's an All-Star
in his Fifth Season 31 a night five
rebounds oh my God shooting 51 he said
30 games of 30 points fifth in the
league and scoring congratulations
Alexander hey what man that team that
team has got a bright future and they
get that big boy back next year who's
sitting out this year yes indeed they
screw around and get a couple more
lottery picks woohoo I was going to be
going back to Brick could you just read
it okay
thank you Jesus
that was rude and inappropriate but
totally necessary that's yes from the
Los Angeles
Clippers Paul George Paul George for the
clips who uh are number four in the west
um his eighth appearance in 2023 where
he's averaging 23 6-5
played in 37 out of their 54 games so
he's missed 17 games with the Clippers
at 29 and 25 right there in the Stick of
things and so Paul George eight games of
30 points or more is an All-Star once
again doctor
it's
oh get very aggressive
from the Portland Trailblazers Damien
Lillard MVP candidate talk about a guy
who's been getting it done not man alive
31 4 and 7. 31 27 yeah had that 60 game
against Utah
sixth in the league in scoring ninth in
assists
oh my goodness
31-4 and seven and an All-Star for the
seventh time in his career
all right I'll do this one
got two left two left
from the Utah Jazz
Lori Market yes well deserved yes indeed
that's uh before it's good to see and
here he has six seasons in the league
and another first time All-Star 25
points a game nine rebounds
[Applause]
scoring 25th and rebounding number seven
in the league and three-point percentage
it's at 11 games you gotta be a baller
when you win a farm though
you cannot you can't have a perm and not
be a great player from Chicago to
Cleveland to Utah now and the Jazz have
already exceeded you know the preseason
expectations had them like at 23-24 wins
and they've already exceeded that Lori
marketing a huge reason why here's our
last one come on I'm a point guard right
yes Simone come on
come on baby come on
give I give out give her the assistant
that was nice of you Kenneth yes
from the Memphis Grizzlies Jaren Jackson
Jr all right Jaren Jackson Jr that's a
good one makes it two Memphis Grizzlies
in the reserve unit his first All-Star
selection in his Fifth Season averaging
16 points a game seven rebounds blocks a
lot of shots shooting 50 percent
[Applause]
he's also missed a bunch of games missed
16 games to play 35 games but
um Memphis 32 and 19 and Jaron Jackson
Jr is on there
um